she's nominated it again tonight and he
made out with my co-host in a movie
please welcome Amy Adams and Jake
Gyllenhaal
many directors began their careers by
making a short like the groundbreaking
very short film with a very long title
electronic labyrinth thx 1138 EB the
filmmaker was George Lucas shorts are
yes
shorts are also the hardest categories
to predict on your home Oscar ballot won
Miss pick could mean the difference
between you ending the night in victory
or defeat so make a point to see short
films throughout the year they'll
inspire you and they might just make you
a winner here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject killing in the
name Jed Rothstein poster girl Sara
Nessun and Mitchell W block strangers no
more Karin Goodman and Kirk Simon son
come up
Jennifer Redfern and Tim met skirt
the Warriors of Qigong Ruby yang and
Thomas Lennon and the Oscar goes to
strangers no more hearing business and
this is the first Academy Award
nomination for both Karen Bookman and
perks I'm
wow what a great year for docks thank
you most of all to the exceptional
immigrant and refugee children from 48
countries at Tel Aviv's remarkable
Bialik Rogue is in school you have shown
us that through education understanding
and tolerance peace really is possible
the love and gratitude to our visionary
executive producer Lynn arason HBO's
finest shield Evans our co-producer an
editor Nancy Baker cinematographer buddy
Squires the courageous principal KarenT
all the children who opened their hearts
to us and the precious Oliver Allegra
Simon thank you